we went welcome to this video playing
swap dinesh master Miller from Germany
I've had this plating handsome many
times and some are never scored all that
well let's see what happens here since
we get into a towel rush defense no one
had this against him before me games
not very quickly to to remember my line
took took a while
yeah this is so roughly equal if black
plays it correctly but I have forgotten
everything if the pit will team I've
looked at this roughly one year ago when
I was working on my onesie for a bit one
yeah this is a move but it is not very
good it's not very good i think i have
to take and now 94 i think was better
for white is 94 may I just wonder yes we
should be five somehow which irritates
me but anyway it is right and this is
the right move but why is it good for
white do I get to the six sets the
problem I don't remember really okay I
didn't feel like I headed on the board
again same ones okay yeah I hit it on
the board the cube t1 now and the m92
King F to lose stuff
may I had this on the water again maybe
against him something to get to look up
in the game library so maybe night c 2
is better angling for 92 III
[Music]
if it takes it what do I play rookie fun
Bishop g4 age three I guess it wins
something yeah not technically easy and
can you have to of course it's a check
what am I talking you yeah this one yeah
i think i think we had this so takes
takes Bishop g4 as a threat keep it
I can do 96 also and Knight c3 if I take
e to and it doesn't really do much shell
to give aid King takes look the eighteen
seventy always has this check on reform
I can also play 95 m
I don't know 93 we have the night
removes them come on I want to play it
simple it was it was just so spend so
much time than he even a solution like
fire why am I have to take first I'm
have to take first of course sometimes
you really wonder what else what I'm
thinking sometimes I wanted to take
first and then I played King III anyway
it's still probably okay that you for
porn it's not something that you should
be able to keep oh maybe maybe you can
keep it shooting for six seven here
check
I still have enough enough for the porn
him he has a hard time to move to move
the hook there yet me just gained some
space I hope the area should have paid
attention to that
that's so difficult for him to do
anything with Maru condescend repeat
just cover all the squares idea now it's
h5 to get it back
there should be 84 Bishop c6 long time
warning
okay not sure about it it should be it
should be okay ready trying for c5 this
one of course honey
[Music]
it's a little bit annoying there will be
six I actually draws this is cook enough
what four bits on time no I'm losing so
many games on time or whatever every ad
exactly exactly the same against him i'm
fairly certain this is right that we are
f5 we should be forced not from the s
good i should probably take on LA
because i mean it's it's almost
impossible to get this position as i'm
just so active but surprised that the
engine actually gives me an advantage
but ok ok just take it ok yeah well why
not him I get the pawn back and this is
not exactly promoting I just basically
just kept the position as it was this is
always equal ish yeah I wonder ever had
a win at the end I mean hold your heads
heroin six I just rotate through a half
of course yeah I just lose a temple I
was stupid you just lose the tempo and I
would enter because he's out of moves
he's in suks one
that still works but then is a draw
that's a draw I should have looked at
this alone would have 10 seconds and I
can still just win with with any book
more I can now go here because yeah now
I'm cook enough to take and promote ok
guys thanks for watching